kiting does feel like flying because
sometimes we actually do leave the
ground and actually fly through there
the feeling when you're riding behind a
snow kite is unlike any other feeling in
the world just total freedom it's a
combination of feeling like you're
flying or gliding across the ground with
no resistance
no effort and just a ton of wind in your
face
my name is tom fredericks and i'm a snow
kiter
snow kiting is basically getting pulled
on the snow with the giant kite
to be able to snow kite you need a big
four line kite a waste harness
that you hook into in your skis
12 years ago i moved to alaska to
establish the first kiteboarding and
snow kiting school
i fell in love with the mountains and
the open air
thompson pass is one of the best snow
kiting venues in the united states if
not the world just because of the
plentiful snow the wide open terrain
and the steep mountains it makes it
truly a world-class venue
alaska kite adventures puts on the snow
kite festival every year we have about
30 to 45 snow kiters come out to compete
at the snow kite festival we offer
clinics races and competitions and also
a community forum for us to exchange
ideas and teach the public about snow
kiting
[Music]
i think snow kiting is so unique as a
sport because it's been overlooked for
so many years it has a small group of
passionate followers
the snow kite community for me is so
important because it is a legacy that i
helped start and to go from seeing like
two or three people when i first moved
up here 12 years ago to about 200 people
snow kiting in alaska that's super
important
[Music]
you